[Music]  all feels really good to me ray  that one's business pigs huh I think  we're gonna be real comfortable here  yeah me too  it's all banned finally went and sold  the place you usually run hotels no I'm  an electrician I just wanted to try  something different  [Music]  that's tens of pitch I'll take him  [Music]  that's her isn't it she was our first  guest the boys over the gas stations  have you filled out of your parking lot  pretty fast  everybody knows everybody around here  except you  did you do did i do what did you do it  you're with that girl  the night she died saw you at my place  watch that it see anybody well why would  I watch your place you told me this is a  crummy we could lose the motel did you  do it did I do Daisy do it thank you  what did you see  did you see something ray  [Music]  you